This is what happens when you push an
ESC past its limits. The ESC is the
literal beating heart of your quad, but
it's also the most likely thing to go up
in smoke. And at 50 to $150 a pop, it's
an expensive game to try and guess which
one is going to be reliable.
So, I decided to stop guessing. I
collected 40 of the most popular 30 by
30 and 20 by 20 ESCs on the market, and
I tortured them, in many cases to death.
I used a custom test rig to test step
response, bolted on a flywheel to look
at torque production and resistance to
desyncs, and then ran thermal imaging on
a brutal throttle ramp until capacitor
legs melted and MOSFETs literally caught
fire. I have gigabytes of data and a
graveyard of dead electronics. And by
the end of this video, you are going to
know which ESCs give you the best
performance, which can handle the heat,
and which ones belong straight in the
trash.
This ultimate ESC torture test is a lot
to get through in one video, so let's
not waste any more time. Let's dive
right into it. Right from the start, I
knew that a simple flight test wasn't
going to be enough. Strapped to a drone
in the air, there are simply too many
variables, and it's too difficult to
gather comparable test data. So, I built
a torture chamber right here on the
bench with each ESC wired to the exact
same AOS Supernova 32 20 motor with the
exact same power supply and put through
three brutal tests. Test number one is
the step response. I commanded the ESC
to step up and down instantly between 10
and 50% throttle.
In the real world, this is your
freestyle punch out. This is your snap
flip or your snap roll. This is you
catching the drone out of the dive. This
test measures the milliseconds it takes
the ESC to convert the command from your
sticks or from the flight controller
into a response from the motor. The
faster the response, the more locked in
your quad is going to feel. Test number
two is the flywheel. Props are light,
but what happens when the motor has to
fight serious physical resistance? I
bolted a 200 kg cm flywheel onto the
motor shaft and hit the ESC with another
10 to 50% step command. This is the
ultimate test for torque and desync
resistance. In the real world, if you
fly heavily loaded quads, you tend to
clip branches or you turn sharply into
heavy prop wash. This test is going to
show you which ESCs have the grunt to
power through and keep that motor
spinning and which are going to stutter
and drop your quad out of the sky.
Finally, test number three, the thermal
torture test. We all know that heat is
the ultimate killer of ESCs. I ran a 10
10 10 throttle ramp. That's 10 steps, 10
seconds per step, and stepping up by 10%
throttle each time.
During this test, I had a thermal camera
pointed at the ESC recording the exact
temperature of the MOSFETs on the board.
I analyzed the video to track the
maximum FET temperature over time to see
which ESCs have the most efficient
hardware, which are the best at
dissipating that heat, and which are
simply faking their amp ratings.
In the real world, this is the
durability test. When you're pushing
hard in hot weather, you need to know
which ESCs are going to be able to stay
cool and which are likely to burn up
under the pressure. Only five ESCs
survived this test. Others I had to pull
the plug when the temperature on the
MOSFETs exceeded 150° and some
desoldered their motor wires in protest
or simply caught fire. Don't forget to
let me know your thoughts on this test
methodology down in the comments. Let's
start with the agility tests and see who
comes out on top. When you punch the
throttle, the ESC takes time to spin up
the motor. Here's the raw data from the
tests and you can see that there's quite
a difference in how long each ESC takes
to spin up the Supernova motor.
To really drill down into which ESCs are
performing best, we have to process the
data a little bit further. Firstly, we
calculate 90% of the RPM change for each
ESC, and then we look at the time that
the ESC takes to accelerate the motor to
90% of the final RPM from the moment
that it is commanded to 50% throttle.
Finally, we divide that RPM change by
the time taken to give an average
acceleration in RPM per second. The
process for deceleration is exactly the
same, except this time we're looking for
the time to go from 100% to 10% of the
RPM change. That gives us an average
deceleration, again, in RPM per second.
Here are the response results. In this
video, we're going to focus on the top
and bottom 10, but if you want to look
through all of the data from this ESC
testing, it's available as a spreadsheet
on my Patreon, and I'll put a link to
that down in the video description. When
considering if you want to support me on
Patreon, I'd like you to know that I
spent about 100 hours creating this
video, and if 10,000 of you watch it,
YouTube will give me about 20 US dollars
of ad revenue.
So, you can see why no one else is doing
test work like this, and why I need your
support on Patreon to be able to keep
going. So, thank you for your support.
Looking at the top 10 performers, we can
see representatives from iFlight,
T-Motor, Flycolor, Voltarra, Air Gear
RC, and Diatone in this list. And it
seems like for the best performing ESCs,
it's really in their breaking
performance where they pull ahead of the
competition.
The very best, most responsive ESCs can
break the motor as fast or faster than
they can accelerate it. Contrasting that
with the performance of the bottom 10,
you can see that these ESCs really
struggled either with acceleration or
deceleration. And right at the bottom,
we have the FETtec SFOC 65A, which
basically refused to do a throttle step
from 10 to 50%. It just disarmed and
beeped some warning tones. Now we know
which ESCs accelerate and brake the
fastest with a lightweight prop. But
what if you've got a heavily loaded rig
and you turn tightly into prop wash or
you clip a ghost branch and stall a
motor? In these situations, you need raw
torque. So, let's look at that next.
This test requires the ESC to deliver
maximum current with perfect timing to
accelerate that fixed flywheel as fast
as possible. You can see that initially,
the test starts at around 2,000 RPM and
the ESCs spike up to their maximum
torque value. Then, as the RPM builds
and the KV of the motor means that the
back EMF increases, that limits the
maximum current that the ESC can push
into the motor and you see that the
torque decreases, eventually hitting
zero around 11,000 RPM, which is the
free running speed at 50% throttle.
Even though this graph is super busy,
you can already pick out some key
features. You can see the peak torque
that a particular ESC delivers. You can
see the moment when it hits an internal
current or power limit and you get this
sort of dip in the torque curve and then
a recovery. And you can also see what it
looks like where the ESC completely
loses track of the motor for a moment
and then catches it again and starts to
provide torque once more. To provide a
fair comparison across all these ESCs,
we're going to be looking at the torque
that they're able to generate at 4,000
RPM. The spread of performance in this
test was massive with the best ESC
delivering more than twice the torque at
4,000 RPM compared to the worst. And
although there was a general rule that
higher current rated ESCs tended to
perform better, we have 55 amp ESCs
beating 70 or even 90 amp rated boards
in this test by huge margins. The top 10
in this test is dominated by T-Motor
with five out of the 10 places. But,
there are really good results from Zeee
X with their Boray and Boray Mini ESCs
and Mico Air as well as Diatone.
Before we look at the bottom 10, I want
to call your attention to something
really specific. The T-Motor F55A Pro
III AM32 came fourth in this test.
If we look at the bottom 10, you can see
that the same ESC, the T-Motor F55A Pro
III running BLHeli_32 firmware, is now
third from the bottom.
But, we have plenty of ESCs in the top
10 that are running BLHeli_32 firmware.
The Pacer, the Mamba, so it's not the
firmware. And we know it's not the
hardware because these boards are
identical. The only difference is the
firmware. This shows that firmware
settings are really important for
performance in this test. And while some
of those settings we can adjust using
AM32 Configurator or BLHeli_32 Suite, we
can't adjust all of them and some of
them are hard coded in by the
manufacturer. The bottom 10 is dominated
by smaller boards with smaller MOSFETs.
And that makes sense. Smaller FETs are
going to have a higher R_on resistance.
That's going to reduce the maximum
amount of current that the ESC can
supply and therefore the maximum amount
of torque that it can generate from the
motor.
And once again, FETtec refused to play
ball. It just disarmed and beeped at me.
So, we know who has the speed and who
has the torque. But, channeling this
much power creates a critical byproduct,
heat. It's time for the thermal torture
test. To see which ESCs could handle the
heat, I put every single board through a
grueling torture test. 10 seconds at 10%
throttle, then stepping up to 20% for 10
seconds, and climbing all the way to
100%.
During this test, a thermal camera was
locked onto the board recording the
maximum temperature of the MOSFETs.
Since my last ESC testing video, I have
put a lot of development into processing
the thermal imagery to make sure that
the timings of the thermal footage and
the test data are precisely aligned so
that we can plot the maximum temperature
of the MOSFETs during the test with much
greater precision.
Oh, and by the way, Thermal Master
software doesn't allow you to export
temperature data for video files. So, I
had to write a custom Python script to
step frame by frame through every screen
recording and extract the temperature
using optical character recognition from
the table to produce these graphs from
scratch.
But, oh boy, was it worth it? Because it
allows us to see exactly how every ESC
performed and the maximum MOSFET
temperature at every moment during the
test. You can see that the throttle
steps up every 10 seconds by 10%. So,
the whole test lasts exactly 100 seconds
with the final 10 seconds being at wide
open throttle.
As you can see, all the ESCs start at a
slightly different temperature.
They're all in equilibrium with the
environment, but the ambient temperature
changed a bit over the several days of
testing. So, the figure of merit that
we're going to be looking at is the time
to increase by 100° C above ambient
temperature. That's going to be how we
compare all these ESCs fairly against
each other.
And here are the results for time to
ambient plus 100° in seconds. You can
see there is a huge range here across
all the ESCs I tested with the best ESC
outlasting the worst by more than 72%.
If we zoom in on the top 10, we can see
a whole range of different brands
represented. Some like T-Motor maybe
more well known, others like Secure and
ZTW Future maybe less well known.
We would expect that ESCs with thick
aluminum heat spreaders on both sides of
the board would perform well. They've
just got a lot of thermal mass to soak
the heat away.
But, that's not really the case. In
fact, five of the top 10 boards don't
have any heat spreader at all.
They're just relying on FETs with a low
resistance and a thick PCB to soak the
heat away.
Looking at the bottom 10, we can see
that smaller, lighter weight PCBs and
particularly ESCs with smaller FETs like
the E55 Mini and the Vortex 40 amp Mini
struggle more with this type of thermal
torture test.
But, we can also see that we shouldn't
put too much stock in current ratings
because there are some serious brands
with some serious current ratings down
here as well. We've got 60 amp, 65 amp,
even 70 amp rated boards that are being
outperformed by boards with much lower
current ratings on this test. I was
pretty shocked by some of these results
and I wouldn't blame you if you wanted
to take a look at the raw data and drill
down into exactly how each of these ESCs
performed. So, I'm going to be making
all of that data available on my Patreon
and there's a link to that down in the
video description. Now, let's move on to
the final scores and to make things
easy, there are links to the top 10 down
in the video description.
And here are the final scores. For those
of you not familiar with how I score my
testing, I take the performance of a
particular ESC in a particular test, for
example, the thermal torture test, and I
divide its performance by the average
performance of all the ESCs that I've
tested to give a score out of 100%. That
means that 100% is the average
performance of all the ESCs that I've
tested. A score of 110% means that this
ESC is 10% better than average on that
test and a score of 90% means an ESC is
10% worse than average on that test.
That gives us a score for each of the
four categories, thermal torture test,
efficiency at 50% throttle, torque at
4,000 RPM, and response.
And then to rank all the ESCs, I simply
take the average of all of those scores
and then rank them according to that
average. So, we have the very best ESC
at the top and the very worst at the
bottom.
Zooming in on the top 10 and we can see
that T-Motor have the top of this
leaderboard locked up. They have the top
four places.
But, there's not that much difference in
performance between the F55 Pro 3 and
the Velox 70 amp despite quite a a
difference in price. So, bear that in
mind when you're choosing which to buy.
The rest of the leaderboard is full of
less well-known brands like Zedi X
Future, Secure, and Oddity RC, which
just goes to show that you don't need to
be a big name to know how to make a
great ESC.
A particular mention to the Secure Blue
Sun A1 and A2 boards, which are both in
the top 10, and you can find them for
about 30 US dollars. So, there's really
nothing that competes with them for
performance at that price point.
The boards in the bottom 10 were let
down by their performance in one or more
categories. Usually, the thermal torture
test or the torque test, or the board
was unable to complete one or more
tests, either due to a firmware
limitation or due to a component
failure.
So, that brings us to the end of this
mega batch of ESC testing, and begs the
question, what comes next?
Well, I've already had a dozen new ESCs
arrive after the cutoff date for this
video that I'm going to be testing over
the coming weeks and months, and I also
want to do another video looking at AIO
boards as well. Don't forget to let me
know what testing you'd like to see next
down in the comments.
That's all I have for you for today. So,
until next time, I wish you all very,
very happy flying.
>> [music]
[music]